let's welcome in now the host of the
reuben report dave rubin he is the
author of don't burn this book thinking
for yourself in an age of unreason he's
back
from his henry david thoreau style
sequestration in the woods someplace no
internet no tv getting caught up on the
afghan disaster the cdc now the fourth
branch of the us government apparently
dave
how are you coping i mean this is a lot
this is information overload coming back
uh from the dark
no it really is i just did a month off
the grid with no phone no social media
no news no current events no cnn which
is the greatest therapeutic thing that
anyone can do for themselves and i came
back yesterday and i'm getting caught up
on all of this and suffice to say yeah
you're right it's just sort of endless
disaster after endless disaster you know
this afghanistan thing which as i said
i'm just catching up on now i mean this
strikes me as possibly the biggest
foreign policy
blunder and i don't even know if that
word is strong enough
probably in the last 50 years i mean
this is a
disaster at absolutely every level and
it's still unfolding and unfortunately
you know as we often talk about on our
thursday chats john you know we don't
have a mainstream media that will hold
the administration to account because
they like the guy that's in office now
if it happened to be that orange guy we
used to have then they would be covering
everything in a completely different way
so you know for me being gone and then
coming back it's like okay this
afghanistan disaster and now everything
that you just addressed about kovid it's
like it's never going away i mean i
think that that's what people need to
understand and what i mean by that is
not necessarily covet the virus that
that will sort of always exist to some
degree
but like the flu exists like the common
cold and everything else but what i'm
more concerned about is these people
like wilinski who you're showing right
there the the government people and
these these
organizational people at the cdc who as
you point out are not elected who want
endless control of our lives to tell us
what we can do on 4th of july and what
we can do on labor day and when we can
go to work and what birthday parties and
funerals we can go to those of us that
care about freedom our work has never
been more important because they are
never going to stop it is really that
simple you know and i know you came back
yesterday but i wish you could have seen
it for a couple days there there did
seem to be some curiosity at least from
the press corps to ask some pointed
questions but that you know has
apparently evaporated yesterday's press
briefing with the
chairman of the joint chiefs and the
defense secretary you know they were
basically throwing softballs up there
and giving these guys a platform to talk
about whatever they want there is no one
in the press holding you know our
leaders accountable right now and going
back to the cdc you know the press now
is is on to their next shiny object
everyone's obsessed because joe rogan
has apparently tested positive for covet
and i think what's so telling about the
coverage of this is how excited everyone
in the mainstream press seems to be that
joe rogan has caught kovid breaking news
from cnn they had to tweet this out joe
rogan has covid using ivor mektin they
say an unproven anti-parasite drug for
treatment here's another one from the
hollywood reporter joe rogan says he
tested positive for covid19 takes
unproven horse
dewarmer
well first off on the word unproven i'm
a little confused are the vaccines
proven or unproven
it won the nobel peace prize in 2015 for
treating humans and you know we've
covered this there's a doctor down in
broward county florida he's been
administering ivermectin under a you
know a medical trial
it is working for some folks you know
people are taking it off the shelf
buying it from a feed store you know
they're taking horse medicine and that's
what everybody in the press is focused
on
well your original point there about the
glee that the media has over this that
joe rogan got it now it i actually don't
know and if you do know you can let me
know if joe rogan was vaccinated or not
i know he had said a while back that if
you're young and healthy you don't
really need to don't think he was
vaccinated i don't think he was
fair enough my position on this has
always been that everyone should do
what's right with for them and their
family and you know the people around
them and make decisions that are right
for you whether that's vaccination mask
anything else but the glee the fact that
it's obvious that the media wants him
not only to have kovid because he was
thought of as sort of an anti-vaxxer or
just someone that was against the cdc
and the you know the lords over at uh
you know health and human services or
whatever um they want him to have it and
they really want him to suffer from it
so the irony is there tweeting all this
stuff out but so far it sounds like he's
taken some medications done what he
thinks is right and i have no doubt that
he's talking to his own medical
professionals and he's not dead i mean
the point is he's a i think he's about
50 years old so he's a you know a
middle-aged guy who's in pretty good
shape i mean most of his life is spent
working out he does all that ufc stuff
and everything else and he's doing what
he thinks is right for himself so i can
tell you john a month away from this
when you come back and you just see how
they're never going to let it go they're
they're picking good guys and bad guys
based on your feelings about vaccines
when we know that again if trump was
president right now and the
administration was pushing vaccines on
everybody and vaccines the media would
be screaming that this is the worst
assault on our freedoms ever right they
did that for the vaccine he talked about
hydroxychloroquine and again these you
know when doctors are saying that this
stuff you know under certain
circumstances for certain people might
actually be effective you would think
the cdc would say hey look there's a
there's another arrow we can put in our
quiver here to combat this but they
don't seem to care it's only about the
vaccine they talk about it as an
actuality if you haven't been vaccinated
yet they act like you're definitely
going to get vaccinated meanwhile we
wait uh for more information as to the
effects john can i can i go ahead the
script here and ask you a question which
is in the last month did the mainstream
media did say washington post or new
york times or cnn or msnbc did any of
them run any stories on general health
let's say why eating right could make
you healthier or we're dieting or
exercise or maybe spending some time in
the sauna or things of that nature
taking a walk getting fresh air getting
yes fighting any of them do that they
don't talk about that and you know i we
earlier we talked about the cdc's new
guidance on inclusive language you're
not supposed to call them uh drug
abusers or addicts you're supposed to
call them people who use drugs or people
who inject drugs they're not homeless
they are persons seeking assistance for
housing stuff like that
you know look if if they actually you
know instead of focusing on this woke
stuff dave and actually on the stuff
that works and being honest with us we'd
be in a lot better position but let's
set that aside because i don't only talk
about the negative here from your
perspective there is some good news out
there we have a front runner for the
republican challenger for gavin newsom
and that is
larry elder who's looking pretty strong
right now we're also hearing that george
soros is getting involved apparently
scared here a half a million dollars
going to support gavin newsom the money
is coming out for gavin newsom they must
be scared to larry eller
oh the money's coming out for gavin
newsom and let's not forget that reid
hastings the ceo of netflix gave 3.1
million dollars to gavin newsom
look the most important thing for anyone
watching this that lives in california
to know is on september 14th you must
vote yes on the recall look larry
elder's my guy i think he is a great
advocate for freedom and limited
government and he wants kids back in
schools and he wants school choice and
he wants people to make decisions for
themselves and he wants to lower taxes
and i get it california is a deeply
corrupt state and those are all going to
be hard compliment accomplishments to to
complete however
there is no one in their right mind in
california that thinks that this state
is being run correctly whether it's the
homelessness or the drug use or the
unemployment or the high housing prices
or the regulation everything is a
disaster so at the very least let's move
on from newsome if you're ju you know
you decide whether you think larry's
your guy he's my guy but at the very
least say goodbye to gavin newsom who
spent 20 grand on a bar bill at french
laundry while he locked the rest of us
down so yes this is great news and i'm
going to devote my next 13 days or so to
making sure that larry elder becomes the
next governor of california all right
well we will check in with you of course
and it really is kind of amazing you
know at
the lack of accountability for people
who fail in leadership positions
in this day and age unbelievable stuff
we're seeing dave rubin great to see you
sail up if you're a lefty that's that's
the way it works apparently we'll see
you soon dave thanks so much if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell